[Aplausos]
[Música]
el controvertido y extravagante
presidente del Salvador nayib bukele ha
arrasado en las últimas elecciones
salvadoreñas el presidente millennial
como le conocen algunos o el Caudillo
millennial como le conocen otros
revalida otros 5 años al frente del país
centroamericano su gran activo una
reducción drástica e incontestable de
los crímenes violentos en especial de
los asesinatos unito que ha hecho de
este país el barrio más seguro de toda
América Latina El Salvador ha pasado de
ser un país en el que prácticamente no
se podía salir tranquilo a la calle a
convertirse en uno de los más seguros de
todo el continente se ha pasado de una
tasa de 106,3 homicidios violentos por
cada 100,000 habitantes en 2015 una tasa
de homicidios que hacía que para muchos
fuese más seguro jugar a la Ruleta rusa
que saliera a comprar el pan a una
impresionante 2,4 en 2023 casi la mitad
que Argentina la misma cifra aquí
lituania inferior a la de otros países
europeos como letonia o andorra vamos
que si se lo contaras a un salvadoreño
hace apenas 5 años Seguramente se reiría
tanto en tu cara que necesitaría un
inhalador para poder oxígeno entre
carcajada y carcajada pero ahora sin
embargo Estas son las cifras de las que
bukele puede presumir y
[Música]
presume De hecho toda su campaña
electoral ha estado centrada en sacar
pecho de los formidables resultados que
ha tenido su política de mano dura
contra los delincuentes y el
desmantelamiento de las estructuras a
pie de calle de las maras para muchos
esto es realmente lo que ha marcado la
diferencia muchos salvadoreños se
sienten hoy más libres que nunca tan
solo por el hecho de poder salir a la
calle con tranquilidad Por ejemplo si a
finales de 2019 más del 70 por de los
salvadoreños decían que la delincuencia
era su gran problema ahora 4 años
después esa cifra se ha desplomado hasta
el 4,3 por. claro que no ha sido algo
que haya salido gratis esta guerra
contra el crimen por supuesto no ha sido
ni mucho menos como jugar a la policía y
Los ladrones en el patio del recreo ha
tenido un coste muy alto y no solo
hablamos de dinero y es que veréis el
gobierno salvadoreño opera contra las
bandas criminales mediante estados de
excepción que le otorgan un poder sin
precedentes incluidos poderes para
detener a diestro y siniestro a quien se
ponga por delante en muchos casos sin
apenas pruebas o yo que sé simplemente
por motivos como el aspecto físico de la
persona vamos que si tienes cara de malo
a la trena por supuesto esto tiene
ventajas al dirigir las acciones en
zonas muy focalizadas se consigue
detener a muchas personas en un pisp
desmantelando así las estructuras de los
grupos criminales a p de calle sin
embargo y este es el problema en torno
al 10% de todas las personas que se
detienen en el país son en realidad
inocentes Y eso que se sepa ojo esto no
lo decimos nosotros sino que lo ASUME el
gobierno con toda la naturalidad del
mundo fijaos El Salvador libera más de
7000 inocentes de sus cárceles a la
fecha son un poco más de 7,000 los que
han sido liberados de estos más de
72,000 capturados quiere decir que el
sistema de Justicia está funcionando y
ni siquiera se trata solo de detenciones
muchos de los juicios contra las maras
han sido colectivos se han condenado de
facto a un montón de acusados de golpe
con pruebas muy escasas la mayoría
seguro que eran culpables pero claro el
problema es que hay
excepciones luego también es importante
destacar como seguramente recordaréis
todos los que estéis suscritos a nuestro
patreon porque os lo hemos contado en
nuestro boletín exclusivo que buel ha
renovado su mandato bajo serias dudas de
inconstitucionalidad nayib buckel El
dictador más cool del mundo reivindica
reelección presidencial en El Salvador
después de que su partido obtuviera la
victoria en las elecciones legislativas
de 2021 el congreso recién elegido purgo
el tribunal constitucional y reemplazó a
los jueces por leales posteriormente los
nuevos magistrados dictaminaron que
bukele podía postularse para un segundo
mandato a pesar de la prohibición
constitucional de la reelección digamos
que después de esta maniobra digna de un
episodio de House Of Cars consiguió
saltarse la prohibición constitucional y
asegurarse un segundo mandato sin
embargo queridos amigos amigas la
intención de este vídeo no es cargar
contra Nay bukele ni mucho menos sino
contaros las claves de su primera
presidencia Más allá del controvertido y
polémico tema de los métodos utilizados
contra la delincuencia vamos a responder
a varias preguntas clave por ejemplo qué
ha supuesto bukele para El Salvador
hasta la fecha qué hay más allá de la
cortina de la seguridad qué se puede
esperar de él de Cara a esta próxima
legislatura tiene un proyecto de país
aparte de reducir el crimen Pues bien
todo esto y más os lo vamos a contar en
este vídeo así que
atentos
hechos no
palabras la vida de muchos salvadoreños
quizás de la inmensa mayoría ha mejorado
mucho con la reducción del crimen eso es
incontestable pero qué hay más allá de
esta cuestión sí no sé la seguridad es
un asunto absolutamente clave Pero qué
ha pasado por ejemplo con la economía
Durante los últimos años Pues bien si
bukele se centra tanto en hablar de la
reducción de los homicidios violentos y
habla tan poo de otros temas es
precisamente porque en el resto de
materias por ahora no tiene demasiado de
lo que sentirse orgulloso la realidad es
que el Salvador no está hoy mejor
económicamente que en 2019 cuando bukele
se hizo con el poder y sí lógicamente la
pandemia de la covid-19 justifica una
parte muy importante de este fracaso por
eso esta será una de las cuestiones
claves de esta nueva legislatura y ojo
Porque aquí las cosas no pintan tan bien
Por ejemplo desde el principio del
mandato de bukele la deuda pública se ha
disparado el actual presidente
salvadoreño recibió una deuda de poco
más de
12,700 millones de dólares y ahora esta
se ha incrementado más de un 40% hasta
rondar los 18,000 millones y Eso sin
contar la deuda del sistema de pensiones
Por otra parte bukele confió demasiado
en el bitcoin para financiar programas
sociales y gastos corrientes a través de
programas de compra de esta criptomoneda
por parte del Estado y pese a todo la
adopción del bitcoin hoy por hoy no ha
cuajado entre la sociedad
salvadoreña a finales de 2022 Poco
después de un año de anunciarlo a bombo
y platillo solo el 24 por de la
población había usado bitcoin para
comprar o hacer pagos y en 2023 los
datos fueron aún peores y eso no es todo
los datos nos dicen que el 66 por de los
salvadoreños ha considerado un fracaso
su aprobación como moneda de curso
oficial y el 77 por considera que el
gobierno no debería parar de gastar
dinero público en esta criptodivisa y a
ver inicialmente la idea Podría tener
sentido puesto que con esto el gobierno
quería entre otras cosas reducir el
altísimo porcentaje de población no
bancarizada en el país y facilitar que
los migrantes enviasen remesas en
bitcoin a El Salvador digamos que el
problema es que a día de hoy Apenas un
40% de los salvadoreños tienen y usan
con regularidad una cuenta bancaria pero
pese a ello solo el 3% de de los
salvadoreños consideran que la
estrategia cripto del presidente ha
mejorado su situación económica y para
la mayoría las cosas siguen igual y no
solo eso es que tras años encadenando
reducciones importantes en las tasas de
pobreza y pobreza extrema estas apenas
han cambiado durante el primer gobierno
de bukele es decir que las políticas de
este gobierno han sido hasta ahora
incapaces de generar un marco de
prosperidad luego otro gran fracaso de
bukele fueron los llamados bonos volcán
un proyecto que consistía en emitir
deuda soberana para refinanciar su deuda
externa y construir la utópica y
cosmopolítica bitcoin City además de una
macropatio de 2022 bonos de deuda
pública a 10 años a un interés del 6 y5
por para recaudar 1000 millones de
dólares con los que poder cumplir ese
objetivo al final no lo consiguió por
ahora el proyecto una de las grandes
apuestas anunciadas por este gobierno ha
sido sustituido por una planta de
energía renovable de capital privado que
ya ha comenzado a funcionar Claro que
amigos el bitcoin y la economía no son
las únicas sombras que muchos denuncian
sobre este gobierno y particularmente
sobre este
presidente Y es que veréis según el
departamento de Justicia de los Estados
Unidos bukele realizó acuerdos secretos
al principio de su mandato con la
pandilla ms13 para que esta detuviera
los actos violentos en las calles esos
acuerdos incluían la liberación de un
miembro que tenía una orden de
extradición a Estados Unidos acortar
algunas penas y mejorar las condiciones
carcelarias de algunos presos también se
ha acusado al gobierno de nayip bukele
de pactar con El Cártel de Jalisco Nueva
Generación para atrapar a Elmer canales
Rivera líder de la marara ms13 a cambio
de 1 millón de dólares para el grupo
criminal mexicano y probablemente
también la vista gorda de las
autoridades respecto a las actividades
de este grupo todo a cambio de ayudar a
cumplir al gobierno su promesa electoral
de reducir los asesinatos en el país sin
embargo el supuesto incumplimiento por
parte de las maras y la ola de violencia
desatada en 2022 condujo a bukele a
implantar el estado de excepción una
situación de excepción que todavía Hoy
casi dos años después sigue en vigor y
que parece ya más la Norma que la
excepción en la forma de gestionar de
este gobierno eso sí ahora las cosas
pintan muy diferentes para bukele Y es
que veréis una vez solucionado el tema
de la seguridad es muy probable que los
salvadoreños le exijan al presidente
millennial en esta nueva legislatura
resultados económicos claros por eso la
pregunta clave es qué podemos esperar de
bukele a partir de este 2024 pues bien
veámoslo
futuro de
incertidumbre vale es innegable bukele
ha tenido durante estos años grandes
éxitos en materia de seguridad desde
luego no seremos nosotros quienes
neguemos esta realidad ni tampoco
quienes no reconozcamos la gigantesca
importancia que esto tiene en un país
que ha sido durante años y años
considerado como uno de los más
peligrosos de todo el mundo ha sido una
política con resultados efectivos que se
ha traducido en un increíble nivel de
popularidad pública bukele es
probablemente líder político más popular
de todo el planeta tierra y desde luego
el resultado electoral donde se ha hecho
con el 8 5% de los votos así lo
atestigua el problema ahora para bukele
Es sobre todo una cuestión de
expectativas que por qué Pues porque su
gran éxito Ya se está normalizando y
digiriendo por parte de la sociedad
salvadoreña una sociedad que ha empezado
a fijarse en otros problemas en otras
palabras que lo que puede parecer una
buenísima noticia para El Salvador y
desde luego lo es que cada vez menos
gente se preocupe por la delincuencia
podría terminar curiosamente siendo una
malísima noticia para el propio bukele
cosas de la política Por tanto la
pregunta es Qué planes tiene ahora por
delante este presidente pues queridos
amigos amigas siento defraudar pero
sobre los planes fuera de la seguridad
se sabe entre poco y
[Música]
nada la campaña electoral del Salvador
se ha enfocado casi exclusivamente en lo
ocurrido los últimos 5 años y eso Ha
sido tanto por parte de unos los
oficialistas como de otros la oposición
demostremos al mundo entero de que los
salvadoreños sí apoyamos este proyecto
nuestro país cambió eso nadie lo puede
negar pero ahora nuestro trabajo este
domingo es garantizar que esos cambios
sean para siempre sin embargo como os
acabamos de contar El Salvador tiene
serios problemas económicos problemas
que necesitan medidas urgentes El
Ejecutivo señaló que había logrado
recomprar deuda soberana por unos 565
millones de dólares en enero de 2023 el
país debía pagar unos 800 millones de
dólares en amortizaciones e intereses de
su pasivo y una cifra similar en 2025
esa es la deuda que el presidente buque
le está recomprar reducir montos de pago
en otras palabras que la situación
fiscal salvadoreña está atada de pies y
manos el país es a día de hoy el más
endeudado de toda Centroamérica y Su
economía apenas crece a ritmos del 2% un
ritmo totalmente insuficiente para que
un país tan pobre pueda escapar del hoyo
en esta misma línea uno de los mayores
retos para bukele de Cara a su próximo
gobierno será conseguir suficiente
credibilidad internacional para el año
2027 cuando se van a producir enormes
vencimientos de deuda pública que por
supuesto El Salvador tendrá que ver cómo
refinanciar pero por ahora el problema
es que bukele no está consiguiendo
generar demasiado entusiasmo en el
extranjero Sí vale Ya lo sé para los
cript fan es como una especie de icono y
desde luego la reducción del crimen le
ha permitido aumentar bastante el
turismo sin embargo cuando hablamos de
cosas más profundas y más a largo plazo
los resultados son más bien malos
fijaos desde 2017 la inversión
extranjera directa se ha derrumbado en
el país y esto es algo que los planes
del actual gobierno no han conseguido
reconducir todo lo contrario el último
dato disponible el del año 2022 nos
muestra que la inversión extranjera
directa neta fue negativa es decir que
llegaron al país menos capitales de los
que se fugaron del mismo y claro esto en
un contexto en el que casi el 10% de
toda la población vive la pobreza
extrema y en el que el 42 por de los
niños son pobres Es algo muy poco
prometedor pero por ahora como os
decimos no hay grandes proyectos
económicos a largo plazo luego por
supuesto cuando se gobierna un país No
solo se mira dentro de casa la agenda
exterior suele tener también bastante
peso y aquí amigos podemos decir que El
Salvador tiene una dicotomía bastante
[Música]
grande y Es que veréis desde que llegó
al poder bukele no ha tenido relaciones
particularmente buenas con Washington de
hecho el propio departamento de Justicia
de los Estados Unidos mantiene sanciones
sobre algunos altos cargos muy próximos
al presidente bajo acusaciones de
corrupción luego sus constantes
encontronazos con la casa blanca y el
informe de los fiscales estadounidenses
asegurando que su gobierno ha pactado
con grupos criminales ha hecho que buk
le lleve ya más de 3 años con una
narrativa bastante pero que bastante
antiamericano recurriendo a tiempos de
la Guerra Fría durante décadas probamos
todo lo que nos dijeron que era lo mejor
para nosotros nos pusieron a luchar una
guerra civil por una causa ajena a
nuestra realidad Porque llevaron el
conflicto entre occidente y la unión
soviética a nuestra tierra Así que como
os podéis imaginar en política
internacional sus desencuentros con el
tío Sam les han empujado a mirar hacia
el otro gran protagonista de la escena
internacional Sí por supuesto hablamos
de China si en 2018 el predecesor de
bukele revirtió el reconocimiento
oficial a Taiwán el actual gobierno ha
redoblado La Apuesta este gobierno ha
intentado estrechar mucho las relaciones
con xin Pin y eso es lo que explica
titulares como este las millonarias so
financiadas por china en El Salvador y
qué papel juegan en la reelección que
busca bukele El Salvador y China
negociará un acuerdo de libre comercio
que Estará listo lo antes posible Claro
que esto podría cambiar en 2024 que por
qué pues veréis no es ningún secreto el
presidente millenial y el no tan
millenial Donald Trump se llevan
bastante bien Y desde luego no se suelen
ahorrar elogios el uno para el otro pero
claro Trump tiene también una Cruzada
abierta contra china Así que si el
expresidente lograra regresar al
despacho Val bukele podría encontrarse
de repente con El dilema de si mantener
los compromisos ya cerrados con China o
romper por los sano y alinearse otra vez
con Washington el tiempo
dirá de todo lo demás La verdad no se
sabe mucho el nuevo gobierno de bukele
va a ser groso modo un gran misterio
nayi pukele ha vivido políticamente de
un tema central la seguridad pero
veremos cuánto logra mantener esa llama
viva queridos amigos amigas con este
vídeo Aquí en vios al politic os hemos
querido contar las principales claves
que explican la incontestable y brutal
victoria de bukele los puntos flacos o
no tan bonitos del presidente
salvadoreño y los retos que tendrá ahora
por delante lo que termine pasando pues
solo bukele lo puede saber como siempre
aquí en visual politic estaremos muy
atentos para contaros todo lo que ocurra
desde toda la familia visual os deseamos
a todos los que nos veis desde el
Salvador mucha suerte habéis conseguido
un logro enorme y habéis puesto a El
Salvador en la agenda internacional y en
la agenda de miles de turistas que
quieren conocer vuestro bello país Ahora
toca el siguiente paso pero dicho esto
crees que la reelección de bukele es una
buena noticia para El Salvador piensas
que logrará resultados al abordar otros
problemas del país más allá de la
reducción de la delincuencia y lo que es
más importante crees que bukele ha
llegado para quedarse Pues bien déjanos
tus opiniones aquí debajo en los
comentarios y habramos debate si te ha
gustado este vídeo No olvides darle al
botón de like y suscribirte a visual
politic si es que aún no lo has hecho un
saludo y hasta la
próxima
i